[Music]
in 1990 my mom was having a big year she
was going up for a huge promotion SVP at
Morgan Stanley at the same time she was
going through a more anxiety inducing
process she was trying to get pregnant
now my mom was the only woman in her
product group and she was a go-getter
she was also 31 and my parents were
having some trouble conceiving this
meant that my mom wasn't just trying to
get pregnant she was going through IVF
her 12-hour workday
now featured secret trips to a broom
closet where she had to inject a large
needle full of hormones while her male
colleagues went to client happy hours
she made up excuses and snuck off for
weekly trips to the doctor my mom
covered her tracks because she wasn't
sure what her male colleagues would
think if they found out she was trying
to have a baby as she hid in that closet
she wondered would her boss think she
was less committed to her job would she
be passed over when they staff important
deals ultimately my mom got that
promotion but along the way she
miscarried now my mom didn't share any
of this with her coworkers and it turns
out it's probably good that she didn't
research on bias against pregnant
employees is far-ranging and scarily
conclusive pregnancy bias is real the
work force is 47% women and more and
more of those women are delaying
childbirth to be a part of that
workforce but the workplace isn't
changing to meet that reality women are
still trapped in their own metaphorical
broom closets it's time to stop the
secrecy and open up a dialogue so how
can employers help reduce stigma around
pregnancy and fertility at work and
improve outcomes for all women all
parents
in the process before we answer that
first we have to ask what is pregnancy
bias to do that we're gonna do a little
experiment raise your hands if you plan
on having children whoa way more than I
practiced having it's the answer all
right
so raise your hands again if you plan on
working while you or your partner is
pregnant same answer great now these are
hands again if you're gonna tell your
employer immediately about your
pregnancy nobody cool all right
so men in the room you should tell
everybody research shows us that once
you're a parent you'll be paid more
hired more frequently can be seen is
more responsible but women for us the
story is different for us Parenthood is
a penalty controlling for hours worked
experience industry and education
pregnant women and new mothers will be
hired less paid less and seen as less
competent the New York Times found
startling evidence of this even relative
to their own evaluations pre pregnancy
once pregnant women were immediately
seen as less committed they were left
out of important meetings and not given
the same bonuses and y'all this problem
is only getting worse the Equal
Opportunity Employment Commission found
that this has been rising for over 20
years when they studied pregnancy
discrimination claims and it's actually
at its highest point ever this could be
partially caused by our changing
fertility landscape the average age of
first child birth is also at its highest
ever especially for women with
undergraduate or graduate degrees take
us again as an example the women in this
room will likely have their first child
at age 33 but this trend of later stage
Parenthood means that for us having a
baby might not be as simple some of us
like my mom
need fertility assistance and treatments
like IVF our time and emotion intensive
they can impact the workday and compound
our fears of being seen as less
committed and though male factor
infertility is the root cause of nearly
half of infertility cases for couples
the treatments fall squarely on the
shoulders of women now you understand
the dynamics in play the reasons my mom
hid in that closet
women are caught in this terrible
tension between pursuing their goals of
motherhood and being seen as less
invested to the careers they spent years
building and pregnancy bias isn't just
bad for women it's bad for families and
employers too so if you've been chilling
because you don't have a uterus it's
time to check back in you need to build
this bias into your budget if you plan
on having a dual income household with
children your female partner will
statistically never recover her earning
power she will make on average $16,000
less a year after having her first child
that's a loss of over a million dollars
by the time you're both ready to retire
and as future employers we need to
prepare for the attrition of valuable
employees from the workforce given the
penalty of motherhood and the rising
cost of childcare many women debate the
economics of returning to work so it's
clear what we must do reduce pregnancy
bias and reduce the economic loss of
talented women leaving the workforce but
hundreds of years of gender bias that is
a lot to deal with all at once so let's
start by tackling the stigma around
starting a family a space we can look to
for inspiration is mental health you
know to employers employees dealing with
mental health are not dissimilar from
women trying to get pregnant
in both cases people are dealing with
highly emotional considerations may be
juggling doctor's appointments and may
fear the judgment
of their co-workers many companies has
successfully implemented policies to
reduce stigma around mental health and
specifically there are three that we can
adopt first let's dedicate HR resources
to pregnancy and fertility
let's sponsor educational programs that
clearly lay out fertility policy and
Family Leave
putting our voices strongly behind these
programs demonstrates commitment to
employees trying to become parents and
it creates a culture of support not
stigma second let's dedicate physical
spaces on-site for women dealing with
fertility there's no reason that someone
going through IVF should be injecting
hormones in a closet creating spaces for
this the same way we do for diabetics
injecting insulin helps dispel the sense
of shame and secrecy and it also
minimizes interruption to the work day
it's a win-win third and finally we need
to share stories not just from women but
from everyone particularly from senior
leadership Deloitte hosted a series of
fireside chats with partners who were
dealing with mental health at work and
the results were immediate employees
immediately said that they felt reduced
feelings of stigma and isolation talking
about pregnancy and fertility the same
way not only serves to educate those who
may not be aware of the impact but it
makes us more empathetic colleagues so
sharing stories is exactly why I'm here
today though the first round didn't go
quite as planned my brother and I were
the successful result of IVF cycle
number two so I'm here but unfortunately
my mom isn't we lost her to a battle
with cancer 18 years ago and that's why
I'm on stage in front of you right now
she would have wanted me to share her
story to keep another woman from
fighting these battles alone
so here's my final ask let's be better
future employers let's think about
pregnancy bias when we design our
workspaces or allocate our HR resources
let's think about pregnancy bias when we
hire when we staff when we promote let's
share our stories all of us let's be
more empathetic employers of not only
women but all parents you've listened to
me now go out and listen to them thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]